شهدت السنوات الاخيره حاله من الاقبال على
ممارسه بعض التدريبات الجسديه التي تختلط
بتاملات ذهنيه ورياضات روحيه يقول دعاتها
ان فائدتها تمتد ابتداء من تنميه المهارات
واكتساب فنون الاداره وصولا الى علاج
الامراض النفسيه بل وبعض الامراض العضويه
المستعصيه فكيف ينظر العلم الى هذا الطرح
وهل تشكل تلك الافكار خطرا على العقيده هل
هناك شيء اسمه علم الطاقه ونحن نتحفظ على
هذا العلم ونحن اهل العلم التجريبي دائما
نضيف لها علم الطاقه الزائد العلم
التجريبي يصف الامور بشكلها الدقيق قدر
المستطاع فعندما يضيف الزائف هو يوجهك ان
هذا العلم او ما يدعى انه علم هو علم غير
حقيقي لا تنطبق عليهم مواصفات العلم
الحقيقي ما الفارق بين علم الطاقه الذي
يروج له انصاره وبين علوم الطاقه المعروفه
في العلم
[موسيقى]
وصولا الى الوان الاثاث والطلاق بين
الزوجين الى اخر ذلك كيف ينظر انصار علم
الطاقه له وكيف يلعب دورا في علاج الامراض
صارت علميا انه هو الى الواحد
بغير ذبذبات كلماته او ذبذبه افكاره ولا
الزبز تبعيت جسمنا عم تتغير وهذا عم
بخلينا نحن نشفض واكيد هيدا من خلال
تجربتي مع العالم اللي انا بشتغل معهم او
اللي بساعدهم ان كان بالاي بي ام سي
بالمستشفى او عندي هون
بمحلات اثبتت قديش هي عم بتلاقي افاده
باشخاص كثير بتستفيد ان كان عندهم حالات
نفسيه حالات
مرضيه
حالات فرديه وفي الحقيقه في العلم في
العلم الحقيقي انت مطلوب منك ان تتبع
منهجيه رصينه جدا في خطوات محدده من
الملاحظه واجراء الاختبار ورصد النتائج
ومن ثم وصول منطقي للاستنتاجات العلم
الحقيقي عندما نضع قانون معين فاننا نبحث
عن المثالب العلم الحقيقي يبحث فان وجد
مثلبا نقض بينما العلم الزائف يبحث عن ما
يؤيده من النتائج التجريبيه ويتشبث بهذه
النتيجه ويترك ما سواها ما الذي
من يرو
جوه هذه
التطبيقات يعني الانسان يحب ان يرى لنفسه
اثرا وان يرى لنفسه بصمه وان يرتاح وان
يحصل على شهره وعلى مال وعلى كذا ما بالك
عاد اذا كان هذا الامر كله لا يحتاج منك
اكثر من ان يعني تاخذ كم كورس وكم يعني
شغله بسيطه وتصعد على الناس ما المشكله في
البحث عن حلول في هذه التطبيقات وهذه
الممارسه هنا تكمن في عده مستويات لنفهم
حقيقه
الخطوره خلينا نقول الاعتقاديه في بدايتها
هو يعود الى المعتقدات
من اوساط اسيا او شرق اسيا بعض المعتقدات
تعود كلها تقريبا للمعتقد الهندوسي فهم
يعتقدون ان هذه الطاقه التي جاءت من الاله
التي هي موجوده في الكون تربط كل
المخلوقات الحيه المخلوقات النورانيه او
التي تمتلك هذه الطاقه الروحانيه بالاله
فهم يعتقدون انك اذا استطعت ان تضبط هذه
الترد الذبذبات مع مستوى من خلال رفع
الوعي ببعض الطقوس وبعض التمرينات بعض
التاملات تستطيع ان ترفع مستوى وعيك
فترتبط بالكون ترتبط بالاله البطولات
الاخرى في وجهه نظري هي الاتكاليه
عدم الحاجه للعمل في مساله القانون الجذب
مثلا في في اشهر كتبهم لهذا الامر مثلا
يقول لك صدق واطلب تستقبل لا يوجد عمل انت
امامك خصم للاسف لا يتعامل باخلاق لا
يتعامل بحرفيه مهنيه يستخدم قاعده اكذب
اكذب اكذب اكذب حتى يصدقك الناس القضيه
اننا بصراحه نتعامل مع اناس يسوقون بطرق
غير يعني غير غير اخلاقيه استخدام الفاظ
ماستر الفاظ علم الفاظ مدرب معتمد شهاده
عالميه شهاده الدكتوراه
ما هي هذه الطاقه ما هي هذه الطاقه نحن لا
نعرف هذه الطاقه المزعومه لكن انت تدعي
انه علم وهناك قيمه لطاقه معينه كيف نقيس
هذه الطاقه وكيف
[موسيقى]
نفرق الحقيقه بين ثلاثه امور علم التنميه
البشريه الا في الغرب التنميه البشريه
التي في عالمنا العربي والطاقه هذه ثلاث
امور مختلفه الحقيقه علم التنميه البشريه
التي في الغرب هيومندي هو احد اجزاء علم
الاداره ويدخل تحت علم التدريب والتطوير
والتحفيز والتقييم الموظفين واختيارهم
وتوظيفهم ادخلوا في كل ما يتعلق بتحفيز
الناس الى ان غلب موضوع التحفيز والتشجيع
على التنميه البشريه فصار ما له علاقه
بهذا العلم الطاقه هو اصلا ليس بعلم ودخل
تحت التنميه البشريه اللي في الشرق لان
اصلا هو ليس له اساس فهذا دخل في هذا
وكلاهما ليس له اساس بعلم التنميه البشريه
الغربي ما هي ابرز مدارس علم الطاقه هي
مظله عريضه تبدا بتسويق يعني مسائل
اعتياديه في الحياه اليوميه فتبدا بقضيه
التامل للصحن العامه النفسيه وا ليوغا
هنالك ما يسوق في قضيه التغذيه
الماكروبيوتك والطعام الصحي هنالك ما
يتعلق بقضيه الاثاث اللي هي قضيه انه
الاصفر يفعل كذا والازرق افضل لك ثم ناتي
الى العلاج بالطاقه او الطاقه الشفائيه او
الاستشفائيه
لما بنتكلم عن وحده الوجود يقول لك ان
الله استغفر الله يعني ان الله عز وجل
موجود في الكون في الخشب في الالم في في
اللبس ففي حاجه اسمها وحده الوجود ان الله
استغفر الله حل في مثل هذه الاشياء فانت
ترى الله في مثل هذه الاشياء ودي كارثه
حقيقيه صراحه لان ده منافس للتوحيد ترويج
مثل هذه الامور رقم واحد اخلال تام
بالعقيده الاسلاميه
وينتهي بالالحاد لماذا لان الاصل اصلا فيه
اشكال يعني كيف
تؤس ما تسميه علما قامت في الاصل على
تاليه الانسان ومحاوله النديه مع الاله
طاقه هي طاقه كونيه كلها طاقه محبه يلي هو
الدين بيحكي فيها والعلم بيحكي فيها
والرايكي انارجي الهول لينج اللي نحن
بنعمله بيحكي فيها سو كلياتهم بينضمجوا مع
بعضهم وهالقانون الجد وما يتضمنه من افكار
وتطبيقاته اثار سلبيه على منظومه القيم
ومنظومه الاخلاق وهنالك دراسات وابحاث
تقول بان من يزعمون انهم يستطيعون ان
يجلبون الافكار الى انفسهم وكذا يصدمون
عندما يحصل نازله نفسيه معينه لا تكون كما
يتوقعون
[تصفيق]
اولا جاءت من اديان اخرى غير ديننا فدخلنا
في عقائد ليست عقائدنا الشيء الاخر ما
حاجتنا لهذه الامور نحن الله سبحانه
وتعالى تعبدنا بالقران الكريم بالصلاه
بالروحانيه بالعبادات القلب ما علاقتنا
بهذه الامور للفل لا علم ولا دين فمن اين
تدخل علينا مثل هذه المسائل هذا انحراف
انا اسميه شعوذه باسم العلم وشعوذه باسم
الدين
اين الحياد وانت تنطلق من غنوصيه وباطنيه
ووحده وجود ومغالات في تاليه الانسان
يجب على الدول والحكومات بما لها من اليات
تنفيذ لها من منافذ عدم تجفيف من ابعد
التربويه للتعليم عدم تجفيف المنابع
الدعويه المشايخ المشايخ والمؤسسات
المؤسسات الدعويه على مستوى العالم كل
مؤسسه في قلب بلد وكل الشئون الدينيه
والوقف وهكذا يقوم على مثل هذه الامور
ومخاطبه الجيل بلغته للمدارس تلعب دور
الجامعات تلعب دور البيوتات تلعب دور
الاجهزه الاعلاميه تلعب دور كبير جدا
[موسيقى]